at number four in our countdown
two young chemists are experimenting
with molten metal what could possibly go
wrong I think everyone should be wearing
safety glasses just to watch this video
put it up put it up put it up this could
have gone so badly we are talking about
molten hot aluminum here and it was
spraying everywhere and you can see even
the lab coat caught fire I mean this was
a very dangerous situation and we're
talking about a lot of heat here we're
talking 1,300 degrees Fahrenheit or 700
degrees Celsius these guys could have
lost limbs so what caused this liquid
metal to explode well the big mistake
these guys have made is they've not used
a mold that is completely dry they
looked at the mold thought it was dry
but they should have put it in an oven
to ensure it was dry any small amount of
liquid water is going to instantly turn
into steam when it's smothered by this
molten metal it's taking up a volume
about 1,700 times its original droplet
size and when it does that it takes
aluminum with it we get this spectacular
explosion of metal I think you know
you've failed when there's a hole burnt
through your lab coat and the bench is
on fire